yeah welcome to yet another video I
never played played the sky really
French I am new new world champion this
is probably what it was meant to be okay
I'll play it played the Benoni i
recently got a new book about the Benoni
that's uh let's see what happens hope
for me this has recently become really
popular and I have no idea how to play
the play h3 and III and claim that
they're better I don't know maybe with
some justification I got this book and
read it I don't know I read it it's a
bit too much I had a look at it let's
put it this way em when I was flying
back from London watching the candidates
tournament and there's a flight back is
about one hour and browse through this
book on the Benoni biotic Bulgarian
Grandmaster Petrov let him look quite
quite okay well researched not not too
biased sometimes if you look at books
and you see that let's say it is a book
mainly aimed at promoting a black
opening that you see that black is
winning all the time you know that this
is this book is probably a bit bit
biased or you certainly want to show
that the opening that you're presenting
is some is good you should still be
honest about it most openings tend to be
around equal sometimes or maybe what
retains a slight advantage at some lines
but it cannot be that black is always
better in your and your main lines okay
so a be no need I put the knight on d5
here to make sure that if a white knight
appears on c4 I can always capture it
andrew creators you're intending the
normal kind of counter play with be five
in in the Benoni mostly mostly making
those moves that look normal I don't
know if you play it this way okay queen
bee three this is a move that I don't
know surprises me a bit but I really
don't know much about that this opening
I would have thought I five would be
normal let's let's go here prevent is a
five and maybe i can go 98 to see seven
and then be five prepare this advance
then the queen is really ugly on b3 if i
get n b5 you really don't know what this
queen is doing them
yeah thankful enough he's spending
really lots of time I'm going for this
night c75 thing he may be can play if F
for now but I don't know f or I have 93
maybe 93 years a good move ok so after
this I think capture and 97 should be ok
preparing be five yeah this looks like
pretty decent for black I don't think
what should have any any ATM okay so be
five is this a moment for be five or not
I can play Bishop d7 first
yeah maybe
you need to be a bit cautious about this
procedure with b5 takes and at the end
this route 87 coming not sure that I
want to see that yeah should play a 5 I
guess so so that on e4 I have f4 and he
cannot play 94 at some stage now
probably is some preparing this so b5
now can I even play rook e8 first and
then be five the sir yeah maybe if he
takes the knife I Monday foul hmmmm I
don't like the smooth i played this too
quickly i like the idea that after baby
5a ba bi monday fat already but to yeah
it's not mandatory for him to take on b5
and open up the same and this is coming
he's um he's preparing this this for
action efore mother effer i have f form
this is not bad maybe after b5 text
takes rook takes rook takes e4 I don't
have that for because the rookies on a
yeah this was probably stupid repaired
okay but who says that I need to take
with the leuco something entirely
different yeah well i guess i guess i
need to okay i can play before but it
doesn't help much yeah come on I think I
need I need I need some open line for
the rook this also shows that you create
was complete nonsense I play would be
eight next so should I take this should
I take the night I don't I don't really
want to take on be too
just like an all right I wait wait wait
wait wait wait play rugby eight he maybe
has night c5 put could be but I've got
rooked XP too young this is very very
complicated come on he's got a little
time if he goes night c 5 rupee Toulon
let's see what happens it feels like I'm
active here I was thinking um night be
50 Bishop b5 don't know where as the
snide hey kid can go to his 6cm can come
on activate this intending maybe 93 at
some some stage
uh-huh
yeah but take it no water rook c8
where's the Queen going oops yet where
do you go now Queen to a one maybe but
yeah I can go to a 15 move the rock then
there's Queen g7 what okay all right
let's let's check the Queen and I really
don't know if it was necessary for him
to do that but uh well I'll take it I'll
take the Queen so let's simplify all
this a bit they've got this check coming
and this is yet another look look okay
so we should be five probably yeah
threatening Queen g3
yeah this was a good day for the Benoni
it has seen worth yeah well I came the
only stupid move really i think was this
route aid idea otherwise seems it seems
pretty okay for black not like the
getchar big advantage but like it's
certainly okay here I felt like a pretty
pretty decent game for most of the time
but I didn't understand why he was
sacrificing the Queen Queen I want so
bad computers on minus 0.6 while it
doesn't seem like winning four black
then yeah just Queen a one I mean this
was just panic you're just panicked here
maybe he completely overlooked that this
move was even possible so sometimes you
are just just not thinking clearly I
know Queen a1 i don't i don't have a big
big move
here I don't I don't have a bit more
money but take here for example you can
just take this and it's not working I
was actually intending this but I don't
know what this is it looks it looks nice
with the two looks but therefore he can
take here and then I thought well there
must be something yep don't know what
exactly maybe I can take
no he just took yeah you know he's
writing yeah I shouldn't I shouldn't
have allowed this night c5 probably yeah
well thanks for watching the Sun it's
rabbit you get some comments afterwards
thanks for watching bye